6 33 now right now about half of
everybody here in clark county eligible
has gotten at least one dose of the
covet 19 vaccine
and there's a new option that opens
today making getting the shot
as easy as possible hector mejia is live
at texas station in north las vegas with
the details
and he's still in his car tell us more
hector
i've been here for two hours straight
hey there bianca and john good morning
so here's how easy the health district
is making this
you drive up and you don't even have to
leave your car to get the shot and it
gets easier
an appointment will get you through
faster but it's not required and if you
need a covet test well you can get one
there too
drive-through style our cameras got a
sneak peek yesterday at how the process
is supposed to play out over the next
six weeks the site at texas station will
be open
daily it opens soon in 30 minutes from
7am to noon
for the first three weeks they'll only
give the first doses then they'll give
the first
and second shots scott black a north las
vegas city councilman and health
district
board chairman says this is part of an
even bigger effort to reach people who
may
have been hesitant to get vaccinated
it's a multi-pronged effort to to talk
about
the science and the facts of it and also
just to convey a level of confidence
letting know folks that it's okay and
it's worthwhile and it's the best
alternative
there are plans for more pop-up
vaccination clinics around the valley
right now roughly half of everyone
eligible in clark county
has gotten at least one dose and while
that's good
it's still not enough to get the
governor to drop capacity limits and the
mask mandate and they have the capacity
to perform a thousand shots every single
day and if this is too far from you
it's not the only drive-through site you
can also find one over
at the las vegas convention center
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now all right thanks hector
really appreciate that information for
folks who need to get the vaccine